plus de six millions et demi
d'ukrainiens ont quitté leur pays qui
depuis le début de l'offensive russe fin
février selon le haut commissariat aux
réfugiés de l'onu en france 85 mille
ukrainiens sont arrivés après trois mois
de guerre c'est ce qu'a annoncé tout à
l'heure l'office de l'immigration avec
moi sur ce plateau deux de ces
ukrainiens qui ont fui dans l'hexagone
caterina ni copeaux colonna voila voila
c'est vous allez bien désolé pour la
renonciation et maxime bondarenko
bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur france 24 pour
témoigner
katarina vous êtes musicienne maxime
vous travaillez dans une entreprise
française d'ailleurs vous avez vécu en
france avant ce conflit j'aimerais vous
poser une première question où étiez
vous tous les 2 lorsque ce conflit a
débuté il y a trois mois tout juste
cette agression russe qu'est ce que vous
avez ressenti le 24 février dernier et
katarina moi j'étais active donc on
était au téléphone avec maxime toute la
nuit parce que c'était quelque chose
dans l'air vraiment un comble que tu de
quelque chose comme ça donc on se
parlait on s'est parlé pendant toute la
nuit donc et après j'ai réussi à
endormir et dans une heure je commençais
à entendre comme des boum comme des tirs
vague et j'ai pas compris qu est ce que
c'est mais après j'ai je commençais à
vérifier à mes réseaux sociaux et il ya
des messages comme c'est la guerre la
russie nous attaquent donc c'est comme
ça maxime vous n'étiez pas à kiev le 24
février quand la guerre a commencé
j'étais à paris
c'est extraordinaire mais j'ai j'ai eu
cette malheureuse occasion de voir le
début de la guerre à la télé parce que
j'ai passé toute la nuit à regarder les
émissions indirectes de kiev vu que la
guerre les se voyait qu'eux
le danger est imminent il ya beaucoup et
beaucoup qui prévenait que le danger est
imminent et oui c'était très stressant
c'était très très dur et je suis tombée
en larmes du début de le début quand
j'ai vu qu'un juge eut ce qui s'est
passé le 24 février est ce qu est ce que
vous vous y attendiez à cette offensive
russe il y avait beaucoup de mises en
garde notamment de la part des états
unis est ce que vous pensiez que c'était
réel tout ça
je pense que c'est réel tout ça
seulement tu as fait quand avez vous
décidé de venir en france
quatre jours après après la guerre et
c'est que c'est éclaté parce que maxime
île magique je veux que tu sois en
sécurité vraiment parce qu'on sait on
sait jamais comment s'est passé et tout
ça donc c'est comme ça donc vous avez
décidé de rejoindre mais qui était en en
france
j'imagine que tous les deux vous avez
laissé delà de la famille derrière vous
en ukraine est ce que vous êtes en
contact régulier avec eux est ce que
vous leur avez
demandé s'il voulait s'il pouvait
surtout vous rejoindre en france
pour mon père est resté actif à et
même ma mère et ma tante c'est l'autre
partie de ma famille sont venus ils sont
venus à paris ils ont pu me rejoindre et
c'est après beaucoup de négociations et
mon père l'a voulu rester qui eiffel a
voulu rester à nu cren pour ces raisons
pour pour plusieurs raisons pour une
raison de
deux surtout pour supporter continuer à
supporter l'économie ukrainienne
parce que selon lui s'il ya du monde qui
reste ça va nous aider à ça va nous
aider à sortir et lui il croit vraiment
à la victoire de l'ukraine dans cette
guerre du coup c'est pour ces deux
raisons que la voleuse l'est vraiment
ont voulu rester et vous vous êtes en
contact régulier régulier mais ma
famille habite à 2 nex de jeu vient donc
à l'est de la ville créneau et c'est
très compliqué parce que si par exemple
ma mère ne me répond pas de les fondre
quelque chose comme ça moi je suis
terrifiée ouais pour ça donc c'est
compliqué car aujourd'hui cette région
et le moment ils peuvent pas par exemple
quitter quitté de nesc c'est pas
possible ils ont essayé de quitter cette
région au début de la guerre non ils
sont venus ils sont venus à kyiv de
temps en temps mais ils veulent pas
abandonner leur maison donc c'est trop
compliqué pour mais comment se passe
leur quotidien là bas
je pense que ils sont habitués à vivre
comme ça donc c'est quand une réelle
était anormal comme nouvelle c'est que
c'est comme ça ils sont habitués tout ça
vous
vous êtes venu en france est ce que vous
avez le sentiment d'avoir été bien
accueillie aujourd'hui oui absolument
c'est ça n'a pas été trop compliqué
cette intégration dans vous vous étiez
déjà depuis un moment mais malgré tout
quel est votre sentiment aujourd'hui je
peux parler de l'accueil surtout de ma
famille c'est de ma mère et ma tante qui
sont arrivés début mois d'avril aux
mêmes fins mois de mars
on a eu vraiment eu disons que au niveau
haut niveau
au niveau documents pour faire les
papiers c'est pas forcément évident au
début et hier beaucoup de démarches à
faire par contre je pense que les
français sont très solidaires avec les
ukrainiens il ya eu une aide justement
pour être famille pour ses papiers pour
pour toutes ces démarches
administratives
effectivement il ya beaucoup de
volontaires qui nous ont aidés à part
les organisations internationales qui
qui émettent les échecs restos qui
aident avec chose il ya aussi le aussi
les volontaires qui
qu'ils nous ont carrément céder leur
maison pour que ma mère m'a temps puis
s'installer et c'est le volontaire
grégory qui a également acquis kato de
famille dans sa maison et il ya aussi
beaucoup de solidarité qui vient de sa
région de val d'oise où ils font le
collecte de collègues de la nourriture
collecte des produits d hygiène qu'il
envoie effectivement la maison
à côté de bail et ça en est très
reconnaissante pour la solidarité de
français
pour l'accueil qu'ont
comme le dit ici et vous quatre noms
aussi mais aussi j'ai racontée comme des
gens très gentils qui tu m'as aidé qui
me comprenait donc aussi peut-être site
est très pratique parce que je parle
français
donc c'est très pratique de m'intégrer
ici est vraiment c'est bizarre mais
beaucoup beaucoup nos amis vraiment
arrivé ici en france
vous avez beaucoup des maras d'or
c'était pas comme à gauche c'est ce que
vous avez d'autres 8 des amis qui sont
venus est absolument mes collègues par
exemple mes amis de creative par exemple
elle maintenant un bordeaux donc c'est
comme ça qu'on me le dise et et vous
vous avez l'intention après cette guerre
de retourner en ukraine où vous comptez
rester en france pour suivre votre vie
ici mais deux dernières années avant le
début de la guerre vu le vide et la
possibilité de travailler à distance
j'ai déjà vécu en ukraine la plupart de
mon temps je passait là-bas et du coup
j'ai eu cette possibilité de vivre du
pays de rester un peu en france de
rester un peu en ukraine ce qui me
permettait de ne pas trop manqué mon ma
patrie et à la fois rester en france
parce que je les aime beaucoup aussi est
ce que ça c'était génial et bien sûr
après la fin de la guerre les death de
revenir et de aider à reconstruire et
construire un pays katarina pour moi
c'est une question sans réponse facile
peut-être parce que simple parce que
comment tu commences à vivre au pays tu
commences à t'intégrer à t'adapter à la
la vie nouvelle à la vie les réalités
nouvelles donc je pense que ça a brisé
mon coeur de de choisir entre deux pays
aux jeux habiter donc oui puisque
compliqué mais c'est comme ça je pense
que beaucoup de craignant maintenant ils
sont comme ça ils sont par moments j'ai
entendu merci beaucoup merci à vous
katarina merci beaucoup maximum pour ce
témoignage merci d'être venus sur france
24 voilà c